if you want to meet jd i'll introduce
you to it i'd love to you want to meet
him i would love jd come in and say
hello to will arnett he's a fan of yours
there he is
your dream boot has arrived what nothing
else
[Laughter]
don't back off your point yeah what did
you say i was just saying your dream
vote has arrived like you know how your
dream boat has nothing it was dumb no it
was not dumb it was done well
you you obviously have a good fashion
sense you dress very nicely i don't
always wear a suit by the way but don't
you think this this kid could sort of
clean himself up a little bit yeah and
by the way it wouldn't wouldn't take a
lot of money now you could go to urban
outfitters right and you could i mean
look at those pants jd the jeans come on
man old man jeans limp biscuit is done
right
i like the nookie song no i know me too
i mean i'm not saying that but i'm just
saying that that style i like well no
style that's fine i don't care wouldn't
he be better off wearing a couch instead
of just
i mean what is that but i will say again
like i don't i have no idea what would
until now what jd looked like but i am a
uh it's the feminist because he's a good
guy he's a good person is the facial
hair working for him i think no it's
it's not that effective but
but you know it wouldn't take much i'm
not looking to be effective no but he's
he he's he's a he's a good person
this is just a manifestation of some
sort of inter right
you don't feel like you're deserving of
of
i would say that you have to you have to
i i would say if i knew you better i'd
say hey jd is a friend of mine and i
don't like to see you treat him this way
say that right giggling and listen
do what will says i think this guy's on
twitter i say i'm not a friend of mine
no
i would say that that you could probably
it's probably just
the way you know the the decision to not
pay attention to your outside your what
do you want him to repeat
jd is a friend of mine jd is a friend of
mine so stop being mean so stop being
mean to him that's it that's it